- [Narrator] Three easy
reasons to visit Miami:
the weather, the beach,
and, of course, the food.
(upbeat electronic music)
Known for its Caribbean and
Latin American influences,
there are some famous dishes
that call this city home.
But we are here for a few
under the radar spots,
that still serve up the
classic heat Miami's known for.
First up, a Cuban dish.
But it might not be what you'd expect.
(fast violin music)
to follow savory.
(electronic music)
- [Narrator] At one of
Miamis longest running
West Indian grocers, there's one dish
you really shouldn't miss.
- [Narrator] When you find
a really good kebab spot,
you shouldn't keep it to yourself.
So here you go, you're welcome.
(relaxing electric music)